this is it the last two parts of this
final hoh competition
could be the difference between winning
500 000 and going home empty-handed
all right ian you're back you're back i
am a long-awaited
second all-star season what was your
reaction when you got
the call i was definitely a little bit
uh excited about it for sure
um you know i was working at the time uh
as a management consultant and i you
know i wasn't really
in love with it so anything to just
break up the monotony of uh
2020 pandemic you know
seems exciting and fun so you're like
get me out of this pandemic exactly
get me out of this quarantine and
actually into a quarantine where i can't
hug
people right it's kind of like that uh
that tweet about like the astronauts
leaving earth and it being a good
choice like that's how i feel it's kind
of funny i think
you know the world has always watched
big brother and thought wow what it must
be like to be locked in that house
it must be crazy now we're all going to
be locked in houses while watching you
guys locked in a house but actually you
guys
get to like touch each other and come
yeah i mean it's gonna be nice i'm
actually like kind of looking forward to
it because i don't have to even
think about it so i mean really good
could this be
one of the first times where people are
sort of jealous of live
life i mean i'm i'm actually looking
forward to the living conditions in
there it's gonna be great
frank's vote goes to congratulations
[Applause]
you are a winner you're coming back now
and you won will you have a target on
your back right away
i think i will uh definitely i mean
there's just no question about it um you
know
last time when i played the returning
players they
kind of had like a buffer a few weeks
this time as far as i know we're you
know vulnerable right off the hot so
i think there's gonna be a target um
that being said i mean
you never know who's gonna be in there
so hopefully bigger targets
do you have the same hunger to win you
had before and has
the way you played the game at all i
think that
um it's it's interesting i think that
like
the monetary hunger is not there
um but more is obviously good
so i think i mean it's pretty close i
mean i'm definitely uh
excited to get in there and give it a
shot and if i'm gonna play the same
yeah i probably am i think uh i think
what i had last time was solid so
i'm just gonna try to do that again so
you're a little more financially stable
now it sounds like
correct not a broke college student
didn't blow through the money what did
you do with the money the first time
well i paid off my student loans i
invested
i bought a car and i put a
really nice down payment on the house
wow you were a sensible college student
yeah i mean for 21 not bad
so this time do you like blow it a
little bit more like do you get yourself
oh yeah
yeah i mean a little bit i mean i i
would say that it's more investment
money
for for this but uh i mean if i want to
buy
like something really uh really really
stupid then i might just do that
what would that one what would it be i
don't know um
i haven't really even thought about it
too much i guess um i've been looking at
like bmw
bikes like the motorcycles
i mean they're just kind of stupid but
it seems fun
so you're heading in and you know when
you first found out
big brother was still going to go ahead
and film even with the pandemic
what was your reaction i mean it does
seem like one of those shows that could
really pull this off could really film
and be safe because people are
in quarantine yeah i actually thought
about it um
and i was like well i mean i guess it
makes sense because you know it's not
like people are coming
in and out of the house all the time you
know once you're out you're out
so you know i definitely thought it
seemed pretty reasonable i mean
obviously there's like
you know people building stuff for us
and bringing food in but
you know other than that pretty safe
space
what's it been like to get the kovid 19
tests done
and to be in the bubble before going
into the house that's been pretty
strange
it's actually i mean it's not that
different than
what i was used to right so i mean it's
i mean it's kind of nice because i've
kind of had like a general
like ease into it just a little bit from
totally normal back in
you know january february to completely
isolated
so true i mean it almost might be like
you go in there and it's oh people this
is so
this is great right right it's probably
gonna be the most people i've
like been in a room i mean it for sure
is uh been in a
room with since like february so wow
yeah what will it be like to set foot in
there again
to see julie chen again i'm kind of like
bracing myself
for that i mean i think it's gonna be uh
it's gonna be difficult for sure
i know like uh looking back it's
it's really strenuous um i mean just
like the way the house smells
is just like it's gonna probably bring
me right back so
definitely um it's just like this forced
air and yeah it just
almost smells like uh stale
like it's this really stale smelling
sound stage yeah
well yeah i mean you're you know it
it's the past it's the memories it's the
right
the nostalgia yeah when you do
set foot in there you know you don't
know who who will be joining you
but you knew this was all-star so as
your mind wandered who are you
excited to see and who would you be
nervous if they were in there i think
like the people that i'm definitely
nervous about are the ones from the the
really recent seasons um it's just well
one i haven't watched
them so i don't know anything about them
and on top of that i know that when i
first got off the show you're really
close
with those folks like the people that
are on their seasons near you and i've
been kind of like out of the mix for a
while so
if they're all buddies outside of here
uh and then i go and i don't have anyone
then that's gonna be a problem what do
you think's your greatest weapon
i think uh the fact that i'm smart i
mean i feel like that's just
the general you know ace in the hole for
me in this game
you know who you're afraid of you know
you'd be excited to see
anyone who you've thought you know if
they were in there
maybe a little showmance would happen
for me uh not this time
so i'm unspoken for so that's off the
table
well that's amazing
will it be hard to be in there knowing
you're missing the person you cared
about
that that's gonna be tough that's gonna
be definitely tough
for sure how are you gonna handle it um
i honestly don't know i mean i'm i'm
having a hard time now
to be quite honest so just gonna
remember that
that's you know it's not we're not going
anywhere it's just gonna
continue at the end of this so could we
potentially see
any breakdowns from you i don't think so
i mean
i i'd be pretty surprised by that i
don't think there's gonna be any
like breakdowns i'm kind of going into
this with like the fact that it's just
like a bonus
so if i win then great if i don't well i
i already won once so i don't you know
this is just bonus baseball bonus big
brother you could say
well my last question for you since you
have already won once
if anything this time around what do you
want to prove
but i still got it you know that i
even though i'm older i can still have
uh have a good time
and play play the game smart you know
i still have it
you